Okay. What do you know?
Let's assume I don't know much,
but I'm a fast learner and I'm a God.
Well, let's start at the beginning.
Here we go.
All of existence
is in grave danger.
The TVA is gone.
I think you mean ATV and.
No, We got in two of them last week.
I need everyone to help us have access.
It's a party.
Okay.
If you're too late,
you would be lost for time forever.
And obviously, when you lose, all of us get.
Here we go.
Listen to me carefully.
Hit the green button.
It can be a little sticky.
but anything can.
So it's now
or never.
There's something you have to see.
Okay.
You are getting desperate here, Little man.
I lost it one time.
Held the whole of New York City hostage
with an alien army.
Yeah. This.
Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie.
They released a Loki finale trailer.
There's footage from episodes
five and episode six. And this.
There are only two episodes left, as they say
during the trailer, so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes Kevin Feige
did say that there would be a definitive
ending during season two,
but there was always the possibility of them
doing season three and this will set up Deadpool 3
Avengers five Kang Dynasty, Avengers
Six Secret Wars.
so, even though they're saying
it has a definitive ending, it is influencing
what's happening
in the rest of the MCU right now.
but even though some of the footage
seems like it's footage from previous episodes,
you can tell they have new dialog.
So it's almost like Loki
gets to relive the events
of the previous episodes and try things
in a different way so that they're able
to avoid the destruction of all reality.
Like when the timeline here
is exploding at the end of episode four,
there are a lot of questions about how
that winds up happening, like maybe he time
slips into his past self because he does time
slip during the trailer, like at the beginning.
Here you see him doing a little bit of time
slipping back to the future
where everything is breaking down behind him.
He goes back to the place where he talked
to Mobius and Sylvie separately,
which Sylvie is calling Pie Land.
then there's another scene of them
with Victor Timely,
who is also back confirming that he is back
because Loki somehow jumps back to the past
with him, trying to learn how to fix things.
And he makes another joke about being a God
like he did with Sylvie earlier.
Like, I don't know much, but I am a God.
the only problem is
that he's the God of mischief.
Like he's
not the God of knowledge or anything like that.
not the God of fixing things.
then the way they edit the trailer,
they sort of jump around in the timeline
a little bit, like he's
shifting through the timeline.
then there's another scene of him
in the control room talking to what looks like
Viktor Timely Kang,
who's trying to fix the device again, this time
then there's a bunch of different scenes
of all the different characters
looking like they're inside regular lives on
the sacred timeline or in different realities.
like Sylvie's in the record shop.
I think this is back in her 1980s reality.
So her reality is still back. Like her.
McDonald's is back, but remember,
that's because Loki jumps to the past.
It's not like they completely fixed everything.
There's much more scene of Cassie in
what looks like his life on the sacred timeline.
And it looks like he's
walking through some kind of prison here.
then they confirm one of my biggest theories
at the last couple of episodes
about Mobius in the Jet Skis.
They confirmed that the jet ski dealership
and all the previous
Loki trailers is actually where Mobius works.
he's wearing the uniform of the business.
And they don't confirm the year,
but it might be during the nineties
that paying off that big season one Easter egg
there are a couple of jokes about him
coming into the business to try and talk to him
and reveal what's going on.
Like the TVA is done.
But this version of Mobius, whatever winds up
happening, doesn't know about the TVA.
No, no.
You mean Atvi, which is basically
like a four wheeler this confirms
what he knows so much about jet skis,
Why he's so obsessed with jet skis.
he was kind of like a professor of these kinds
of personal watercraft, personal vehicles.
In episode one.
Loki walks back into the TVA control room.
You see that screen breaking down
with Miss Minutes on it again.
But everything is turning to spaghetti.
There are a couple of different scenes in the
trailer with things turning into spaghetti
there we see Loki jumping back to him
during the events of season one,
or maybe this is during
a different part of the timeline.
But he's back in the TVA prison jumpsuits
like he's been arrested again.
so it's not really clear
if this is the events of season
one or they just wind up capturing him
at the beginning of the TVA
like an episode one where he jumped back
to the very beginning of the TVA.
because they cycled through
all the different faces of the characters,
it sounds like he has to go around collecting
them again, bringing them back to the TVA,
in as part of this.
There is more Victor timely footage
confirming that Victor timely is back
this brand new footage of Obi
working on a bunch of stuff
like you see a bunch of the message tubes
that he's pounding on and sending away.
Just pause and zoom in
and hands around this part of the video.
Let me know if you think you spot
any other Easter eggs that are strewn about.
There's just so many thousands and thousands
of things strewn around this frame.
It just feels like there's a lot of Easter eggs
here in the background.
there's another scene of different versions
of Loki from different parts of his timeline.
Seeing each other like, wait a minute,
you look familiar.
some of this looks like a repeat of the even
earlier episodes where he's joking about Mobius
losing all of his skin.
that it's not totally clear if the scene of
Victor timely Kang being turned into spaghetti
is him getting turn to spaghetti again
like it's a brand new version of this.
or if it's just them.
Recapping the events of episode four
at the beginning of episode five, There's brand
new footage of Loki giving someone instructions,
though, so this might be Victor Timely.
Kang He's talking about hitting the green
button, activating this device.
There's a bunch of footage of the timeline,
but everything is green.
So this might be the perspective of Loki
going throughout his own timeline,
or Loki using his magic,
traveling through the timeline.
it looks just like the timeline effect
that we saw in the previous episode.
But everything is green like Loki's magic.
there's footage of all the characters inside,
another room that we haven't seen yet.
more footage of Miss Minutes
and then a bunch of scenes that we saw
in episode four, sort of like replaying
those events more footage of Ravenous Ren Slayer
on the Void planet,
the Purple Light probably is alive, More footage
of Loki talking to Sylvie with everything
turning to spaghetti around them,
then Loki himself outside on the bridge, walking
to try and fix the device without a spacesuit.
This last scene.
Those combined voiceover dialog
with Miss Minutes showing Raven
wrestling her back story with he who remains
combined with Loki from the end of episode
four, though, a little more Loki time
slipping back to this same room with everybody.
It seems like after he's collected them
and brought them back from the sacred timeline,
different parts of the timeline.
it. It's not totally clear
if this scene of them interrogating
Hunter X5 is the exact same scene from before.
Like they just copy
pasted it from a previous episode
or if it's like a totally new version of them
doing this
Same thing with Loki explaining the events
of the first Thor movie in the first Avengers
movie in why he took over Earth for Thanos, this
might be the scene from the previous episode,
or it could just be them replaying the events
because they basically said
this is like the mid-season trailer
with footage from the last couple of episodes.
so there might be footage from previous episodes
that are just mixed into this
there's a whole bunch of new twists here.
But like I said, it just seems like Loki times
slips into the past and it gets an opportunity
to replay events like a redo on everything
so that they can avoid
the destruction of all reality.
But whatever they wind up
doing at the beginning of episode five,
like however they wind up explained this,
a bunch of them wind up on the sacred timeline
and Loki
has to go around to their different parts
of the timeline and get them back.
so it might be them
actually rebooting the timeline or might
just have something to do
with Loki jumping around in his own timeline.
the sort of goes back to the old adage
that how do you fix things?
The easiest way in troubleshooting
is unplugging it and plugging it back in.
Just reboot the multiverse,
reboot the sacred timeline.
they're actually kind of using Avengers
six secret wars for that.
It'll make a larger sense for Marvel.
I did a big Marvel reboot video.
It's more of like a soft reboot.
Well they'll tune things
so that after Secret wars the MCU will look
a little bit
more like the true 616 comic book universe
where everybody coexisted on the same planet
the entire time.
like the X-Men characters.
Fantastic for all the Avengers
characters, Everybody from the comics.
The way that Kevin Feige
had always wanted to be able to use
all their characters together in stories
The only thing we don't see
a lot of in this trailer
from the last couple of episodes
Is Miss Minutes in Rent Player?
I think there's a little bit of rent player
on the Void planet.
Not really explaining how she winds up
making it back to the TVA.
there was also a little more footage
in some of the previous trailers of Sylvie
fighting someone inside he who remains Citadel
at the end of time, so she might be fighting
wrestler there or it might be them redoing
the events of the end of season
one was will probably get some more
he who remains version of King do explain
a little bit more about what actually happened
they give us a little teaser
for Wren Slayer's backstory, but
we might get a little bit more information
about what actually happened.
even though they're billing rent, Slayer
is like one of the big villains this season,
like she's turned into one of the big villains.
Ms.. Minutes seems like she is the over
the top cartoon level villain.
Like just look at her face as she's watching
all the different hunters get squished.
that is the face of true evil.
really hoping they also pay off that line
where she wants a body,
but they might wind up leaving it there
like some future story
if they don't kill her off
at the end of the season.
But if they do kill anyone off
like any of the villains
this season, it would be missed minutes.
talked about this in a previous video too.
there's always the idea that they kill her off.
But in an Ultron kind of way, where there's
always a chance that she comes back
Because essentially she's
an artificial intelligence, a program.
So pieces of them can survive,
so she can hide a piece of herself
and use that as a way to come back in the future
at some point.
but I'm not expecting to see
like a huge Deadpool cameo or anything like that
or like a big Thor cameo.
I think they'll
just be like references to the other big things
that are happening in Marvel right now.
post all your predictions in the comments
below in my full Episode five video
we'll post later this week
after they release it.
Big Reminder Invincible Season
two episodes are starting this Friday too.
I'll be doing weekly
episode videos for that is fantastic.
Is probably one of the best series,
not just best superhero series,
but just best series in general.
we're also supposed to get the first trailer
for the Echo series at some point this week.
So of course, I'll do a video for that
When they release it, Daredevil
and Kingpin will come back and be really,
really big characters during that click here
for my Loki Episode 5 video.
Update the link as soon as I post that
and click here for all my other Loki videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!